derivatives of exponential functions
let's begin with the nice neat one this
is the easiest a lot it's just in the X
fantastic if I say e to the power of
some function of X this is chain rule
right function of a function there's the
inside inside here excuse me is the
outside so when you do chain rule excuse
me allergies you have to do each in
sequence you've got to remember to do
both right so what would we call the
derivative of the inside function in
this case just call it f dash there's
the inside when you differentiate the
outside it's an exponential well what
happens when you differentiate an
exponential function nothing happens so
you just get back what you started with
so far so good
all right now this one here we had to do
a bit of mucking around to change the
base does any remember off what else we
get it's very similar to this one
it starts with a DX but it's off by a
scaling factor do you remember that what
was the scaling factor it's gonna be log
a yeah now this is the kind of one where
it turns up in frequently enough that
it's a little harder to remember but go
back we did the proof it's not that
difficult okay now just before we jump
off there I want you to remember every
time you make a statement about
differentiation like this you make a
statement about integration as well so
just because I've got the space right up
here I'm gonna write this one here if I
were to integrate the right-hand side I
should get back to the left right I'm
doing everything in Reverse so therefore
this will be giving me e to the X with
one difference plus the C right plus the
constants so you can see that I could
have come from any of those and you
would have gotten the same derivative
and you can keep on going we'll come
back to those in a minute
right logs so when you differentiate the
nice base a log base a of X and I've
just written it the short way what are
yet yeah you get the reciprocal function
the hyperbola yeah it's worth noting
again if I came from here then where
you'd end up with is just the part of it
that applies to log X and
only half of it does right so if you
wanted to be all specific you'd say that
okay what about when we do chain rule
what happens okay it's really nice and
easy to remember right it's F dash on
earth it's just like this you do the
inside then you do the outside lastly if
you change the base remember we needed
to go back to our log laws to do this
one how would I rewrite this in order to
make it workable in base e what's just
the before I differentiate what is the
change of base rule tell me that I can
rewrite this as very good log X or
whatever base I choose I'm going to
choose base e over log a the a started
on the bottom down here so it ends on
the bottom over here okay being that one
over log a is just a constant I know
that once I differentiate sorry I'm
gonna be naughty just cuz I've run out
of space on my white board that's gonna
be just like this right except there's a
1 over log a as a constant so it's gonna
be 1 over log X log is probably the best
way to write it X log hey it's probably
less ambiguous to write it like this
rather than log a X because then you're
like it's the X in the log or not it's
not so this makes it really clear
wonderful so just like before how we
said this statement of differentiation
makes this step in that integration
let's now have a look at using reverse
chain rule on these Exponential's right
so what I'm searching for is something
that looks like this if I find something
that looks like this I can integrate it
to come back here does that make sense
so if you wanted to summarize that in
rule you'd say the integral of F - a to
the F F - e should send you back to this
guy just e to the F does that make sense
so that's what I would like if I can see
e to the F and then F - there at the
same time it's just like looking for F -
f just it looks slightly rearranged okay
so how I got that here
what's f of X in this case it's the
power right it's one plus three X so
what would F dash be for this particular
function f dash would just be three now
I don't have a three there right but
that's okay three is just a constant so
if I want three all I have to do is
compensate by dividing by three out the
front is that okay so I've done this in
order to have F dash e to the F in the
inside that's the thing I want to
integrate that's just going to be equal
to this so the 1/3 is still hanging out
the front because it's not part of the
integration and then what do I end with
e to the F does that make sense which in
this case is 1 plus 3x
it was indefinite so what am I missing +
see happy times ok now have a look at
this guy remarkably similar even though
it looks so very different it's a
question but I hate dealing with
questions when it comes to calculus I
want to get away from them as quick as I
can so how can i rewrite this guy so
that there are no questions involved any
suggestions say a bit louder Russell
okay so Russell's actually done two
steps here I'm gonna do the first one
the in-between one and then I'm going to
go to Russell's step this part here
right my index laws tell me that's just
e to the 2x is that ok I'm just
multiplying those powers indices are
fine but Russell saw the next step
already which is that this is on the
denominator I want it up the top so I
can write it with a negative index sad
ok usually we don't like negative
indices because they're gross and
awkward to work with but with calculus
they're much better okay I'm still not
quite there yet this is not in this form
I've got e to the F but I've got no FD
so what would F dash B in this case yeah
negative tooth that's the derivative so
if I want a negative 2 in here then what
do I put out the front to compensate
negative 1/2 do you see it'll cancel
cancel and send you back now I'm pretty
much ready to go the negative 1/2 is
outside the process of integration so
that's why it remains untouched what do
you end up with what's your integrating
universe say to get America very good
there's that eat of yet plus I see very
good ok now just a little um a little
side note can I rub off this left hand
side well I'm talking said ok just a
little side note you'll sometimes see
all of this written slightly differently
because F dash notation is not the only
way to talk about derivatives so for
instance let me show you this stay with
red if I had this in this form
let's go like this ok so what are we
looking at here so U is a common letter
that we use for substitution right so we
would often say let u equal and then
it'd be the form 1 + 3 X or the minus 2
X or something like that
ok now this looks a little bit weird
because you've got a function in you
you're trying to integrate with respect
to X so what do you do okay when you do
substitution normally what do you have
to do as an extra process over here to
change this into the right thing what do
you do yeah you choose some let u equal
blah blah blah right and then you say
okay well let's differentiate that blah
blah blah and get something out and then
that that guy there allows us to switch
over okay now watch this if I insert
that into here right if I have the
derivative inside here that D or DX
watch what happens okay
e to the U times du u DX if it were
there times DX right what happens with
the DX's they just cancel
and this of course like this is just a
regular exponential it's just e to the U
plus C now just compare this with what's
written over there okay oops
e to the U plus C that's exactly the
same as this do you see that just
labeled slightly differently just a
different letter and different notation
yeah what about this line here do you
see how similar this is to what's been
written here where's the e to the f of X
over here what's the equivalent it's
this guy e to the u right what's this
guy equivalent to that's f - do you see
it just written in different notation
because it's not F it's you does that
make sense but of course it all cancels
out because these derivatives can act
just like fractions in this context all
right